[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a japanese science fiction
thriller film called ai amok
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
is a brilliant scientist from japan who
has developed an advanced ai called hope
for medical purposes his main motive for
all the hard work he has put into the ai
is his wife's cancer treatment if the
technology is approved by the government
to be used in the medical sector it will
not only save his wife's life but will
be a revolutionary step in human
development at the beginning of the
movie kiryu is in his lab working when
his brother-in-law satoru nishimura
comes to him with some paperwork it
turns out that the government has
refused to endorse the use of ai because
of the absence of relevant jurisdiction
in the following scene kiryu his wife
and satoru are on a beach with kiryu's
daughter kokoro his wife is in the last
stage of cancer and needs immediate help
from the ai although kiryu invented the
ai he and his wife refused to use it
illegally without proper authorization
the family takes a picture together at
the beach a few days later kiryu's wife
is on her deathbed she passes away after
saying that she hopes the ai will one
day bring joy to many people's lives if
it had been approved in time kiryu could
have saved his wife a year after her
death the medical ai system is approved
by the government and distributed among
the people not long after it starts
being used in every sector like law
finance entertainment and most
importantly medical because of the
technology cures for several diseases
are found in only a few years kiryu's
achievement is belatedly celebrated
worldwide his brother-in-law satoru
becomes the president of hope managing
it overall after fulfilling his wife's
dying wish kiryu doesn't want to live in
japan anymore so he and his daughter
move to singapore the popularity of hope
rises exponentially when a personalized
watch that takes care of one's health is
introduced now people do not have to go
to the doctor to be diagnosed with
problems like brain tumors and cancer
what fun who wouldn't want their watch
to tell them they have a brain tumor
although most of the world celebrates
the new invention there are some who
believe that it will cause the problem
of unemployment to rise exponentially
many people protest against hope but it
has become indispensable to the lives of
most japanese citizens
in 2030 kiryu and kokoro are living in a
beach house in singapore however kokoro
misses her mother a lot and desires to
return to japan one day they get a
message from satoru saying that the
president of japan wants to award kiryu
for his achievements taking the
opportunity the father and daughter fly
back to japan and are surprised to see
several protesters outside the hope
headquarters they are welcomed by satoru
and the entire company with a round of
applause following that they are given a
tour of the building they get to see the
server room where the heart of hope is
kept it is a massive machine that serves
as the core motherboard of hope the
place is tightly secured because the
machine is connected to the lives of
every hope user two drones from the
heart recognize kokoro using their face
scanning feature following the tour a
press conference is held to welcome
kiryu and for him to talk about his
invention during the conference the
protesters managed to break in and
interrupt kiryu while he is talking
following that kiryu meets a police
officer named sakuraba sakuraba has been
bothering satoru to let the police
department use hope to hack people's
personal belongings and solve crimes
since it would be a breach of people's
privacy he has been denied the orwellian
request for once the stalkers are being
shut down on his way out kiryu is
followed by a journalist who is clearly
against ai he hands gear you his card
claiming that he wants to interview him
when kiryu and kokoro are in the car the
little girl notices that she has lost
the only picture of her mother she runs
inside with the staff to look for it
while kiryu and a girl drive to the
convention where he is being awarded by
the president kokoro and the others go
to the server room to look for the lost
picture meanwhile in several different
hospitals in japan hope suddenly starts
to malfunction many patients die because
of the lag while the medical workers
panic not knowing what is causing it
somewhere else the president is
preparing for the program but she
suddenly drops to the ground it turns
out that her heart pacer also ran on
hope which has stopped working she is
rushed to the hospital but to no avail
the automated driving system that uses
hope also malfunctions causing several
accidents as hope stops working
throughout the nation satoru and the
engineers in the headquarters are
informed they run to the control room to
find out what is wrong with the program
leaving kokoro alone in the server room
because of the breach in the system the
security lock is activated and kokoro is
locked in the news makes it to the tv
and kiryu also finds out about the
malfunctions when he calls his brother
he is even more worried to see kokoro
locked alone in the server room with
time the room's temperature will drop
below zero for the machines to cool they
have to bring her out before she dies of
cold the programmers at hope get to work
and find out that there has been a
strange login to the protected server
which supposedly caused the malfunctions
they locate the area where the hacker is
and send little insect-like filming
devices to the location meanwhile a
worried kiryu is stuck in traffic he
opens his bag and finds a tablet that is
uploading the virus to hope just then
the police locate him and arrest him for
being the hacker it is clear that
someone is trying to frame him but kiryu
has no way to prove it just then a car
accident takes place nearby that
distracts the police and kiryu manages
to escape throughout all of this the
journalist from earlier is taking his
pictures from a car behind him with the
suspect escaping sakuraba and his team
are given the responsibility to catch
him taking the opportunity sakuraba uses
the hope ai program to look for kiryu
without waiting for permission so much
for the ai malfunctioning i guess two
officers named godot and asano are also
added to the team to help them goto
doesn't feel comfortable seeing sakuraba
invading the public's privacy to look
for kiryu using cctv cameras cameras
from people's dashboards and even
cameras from people's mobile phones
sakuraba is able to locate kiryu at one
point kiryu realizes that he is being
watched so he enters the sewers he calls
satoshi from there and tells him that
someone is trying to frame him the call
is being traced so sakuraba and the team
can hear them talking kiri reveals that
when he first created hope he made sure
to program that it worked for human
comfort and satisfaction he believes
that in recent years someone has
programmed hope differently that is why
it has started to work on its own and
not take human commands the ai will soon
evaluate citizens and terminate those it
deems worthless this puts the whole
nation at risk of being killed by the ai
just then we see an infant in a stroller
that is run by the ai it calculates the
overall medical bill that the infant
might have to pay in its entire life and
deems it to be unworthy of life
following that the stroller activates
yeet.exe
and falls off the stairs
i can't read the slide
eliminating the baby to stop the mass
murder a new program must be input to
the server after the call ends the
soldiers enter the tunnel and find kiryu
he breaks his tablet so he won't be
tracked sakuraba loses all stats about
his location after that and kiryu yet
again manages to escape goda and asano
get out of sakuraba's control room after
hearing kiryu talk to satoshi goda
believes that he is innocent the two
think from kiryu's perspective and come
to the conclusion that he will probably
go to hope's second data center in
sendai
back in the headquarters everyone tries
to get kokoro out of the server room but
they're unsuccessful she lies in front
of the heart cold and scared to reach
the data center in sendai kiryu boards a
ferry hiding inside a truck goda and
asano also get on the same ferry kiryu
had stolen a tablet from a person which
he uses to program the police track the
signals and find out his location the
officials at the ferry are informed and
told to check everywhere for him when
they eventually find him he makes a run
for it and ends up on the top deck goda
and asano tell him they are there to
help but before he can reply a sniper
from a helicopter fires at him to save
his life kiryu jumps into the water and
disappears a while later he opens his
eyes and finds himself on a boat in a
harbor at sendai a local fisherman has
saved him from drowning he says that he
is thankful for hope because it saved
his wife's life and lets hear you go
meanwhile many protests against hope are
being held throughout the country kiryu
has been declared a terrorist by the
media in sendai kiryu goes to an
abandoned university that was the place
where he first invented hope he is soon
joined by satoshi it turns out that when
they talked on the phone the last time
he used a code word to call him there
goda also debunks the code word and
drives to the university with his
partner kiryu and satoshi start writing
a program to stop the destruction being
caused by hope the computer scans every
citizen of japan who uses ai and plans
to terminate them according to their
past it will take exactly six hours for
the mass murder to begin the engineers
at hope headquarters also find this out
and start calling their families to ask
them to stay away from their ai devices
here you then figures out that no one
had hacked the program and the virus was
manually planted in the heart unchecking
the heart's data for the past few months
they find suspicious activity but on
checking the cctv footage kiryu is
shocked it turns out that satoshi was
the one who uploaded the virus however
satoshi denies the claims saying that he
was just doing a regular check and
doesn't know what went wrong just then
the soldiers arrive at the hideout and
fire at kiryu to save him satoshi jumps
in front and gets shot instead with his
final breath he begs his brother-in-law
to save the people kiryu manages to
escape yet again while being followed by
the police
goda and asano also follow them in their
car amidst the chase kiryu's car falls
off the road and crashes several feet
below the police check for him in the
wreckage but do not find his body police
officer sakuraba uses ai and the cctv to
look for kiryu and finds him but when
the police reach the location the person
turns out to be someone else it is then
revealed that kiryu has bugged the
police's ai system causing it to
malfunction while they try to look for
him kiryu manages to return to the hope
headquarters and meets the chief
engineer who is willing to help him stop
the massacre that is about to happen
however sakuraba and his team somehow
make it to the headquarters and surround
him kiryu tells the soldiers that the
real culprit is actually sakuraba then
he plays a video of satoshi inputting
the virus to the heart it turns out that
he was actually tricked by sakuraba who
was standing outside the server room
when it happened even though it is
proven that sakuraba caused hope to
malfunction the soldiers still follow
his orders sakuraba then says that japan
needs a powerful system to rule the
world with something like ai he could
have all the power in the world as he
confesses to all of his crimes a flying
insect-like device records their
conversation and broadcasts it live to
the entire world the fact that sakuraba
didn't see this coming is incredible now
everyone knows the truth goda arrests
sakuraba and takes him away while kiryu
runs to repair hope and save his
daughter he programs the code and makes
the heart scan it with kokoro's help he
finally remembers its past and the
reason for its creation the door to the
server room opens and the father and
daughter reunite good thing it takes
over a week for the computer's
temperatures to drop subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching